because justin herbert was drafted one
spot
after you i kind of feel like your
careers will always be intertwined you
know
how do you feel about that comparison
that will forever
be made whoa
i i just think that's you know that's
just something that's gonna have to be
dealt with
in the media i mean i have no animosity
towards
torches and herbert and for me it's not
even a competition between me and him
um it's a competition for for myself to
go out and
you know see what i can do to help our
team be successful against their defense
um you know and i'm pretty sure it's the
same for for justin as well
tattoo's been a really great guy to
watch um he's been fun to watch and
he's had so much success over the past
couple of years that uh
you know it's been great to watch him
and all the things he's done so really
looking forward to playing against him
this week and saying hi
you know wouldn't you like to see one of
these guys say
i really hate that guy i just despise
him
i want to beat his brains out you know
it's
they never do that and and and frankly
frankly
how do i word this i think we've gotten
a taste of that kind of personality for
the last few years and i could do
without it for a while let me just leave
it at that
um so uh that said herbert and two are
getting together this weekend pick
number five and pick number six in the
draft and
this one is fascinating it's kind of
like peyton manning ryan leaf
light because the dolphins could have
taken
either guy they took tua herbert is the
leftover that the chargers
settled for so far herbert has looked
better
than tua we've seen more of him
fascinating
uh match up and and and i hope they
cross
paths frequently and in theory they
could play every year depending upon
where they finish in their division
but i hope we see a lot of tua and
justin herbert in the coming years
you know mike i i've thought this ever
since the draft and then early in the
season when we're all saying oh my god
look at justin herbert man was he pro
ready and you know
looking back on hard knocks
when justin herbert was very very
painfully honest about himself a few
times in that show
about how oh man i blew that one or you
know he was very self-deprecating
but the larger point is this mike there
was a little bit of an
aura about justin herbert coming out of
oregon and here's why over the last two
years when he got to be a
very prominent top 10 prospect
okay what would happen okay nfl scouts
knew all about them but
the average people other than absolute
college football nerds or reporters
okay said i'm not staying up to watch
him at 10
30 every saturday night you know because
their games are on their games are on so
late meanwhile
two is on the gary danielson game every
week
you know he's on national tv almost
every week
so you know everything about tua and you
know about one
tenth as much about justin herbert
and so i alway i felt coming into this
year
that of the three quarterbacks i said
burro
he's gonna kill it and of course he is
but the other two guys we knew a lot
about
tua and there was a little bit of a
shroud around justin herbert that he is
just totally ripped off in the first
half of this season
and just the circumstances pursuant to
which he
entered the fray for the first time
tyrod taylor the misadventures with a
needle aimed at numbing a rib injury
punctures a lung
literally a moment's notice for justin
herbert and he never looks back
the only unfortunate aspect of it is
peter that the chargers haven't been
able to rise to that same level
they're two and six as my son said over
the weekend
they must be the worst two and six or
the best two and six team
in league history they're in every game
they've blown three 17-point leads
they had a flukey little almost won the
game last week horrible clock management
down the stretch so they would have had
more chances at the end zone
to beat the raiders and and as i said
the other day
herbert is playing just well enough and
the team is playing just
poorly enough to get everybody fired
after this season because what a prime
job that would be
if that comes open with justin herbert
there for the next 10 or 15 years
yeah i mean look uh if they continue on
this path
it's gonna be very easy for uh the
spanos family to basically say we gotta
make a change
i can tell you this right now mike they
absolutely unequivocally
do not want to get rid of anthony lynn
they love anthony lynn
but you know you you got to stop the
bleeding at some point
and and so this game becomes
really important just like the rest of
them do but
you know look i'll say this also about
the dolphins
you know at the beginning of the year i
picked them to win the division
and i didn't really know why i just knew
that i really liked brian flores
i liked what they were doing and i
figured that at some point during the
year
two would play and he would start to if
not dominate
play very influential football both
running and throwing
and so far he he has it's only been two
games
but i think he's shown promise but the
thing about the miami team right now
mike
that gets buried by
you know the tui show their defense is
really
really good i think their defense
potentially is top three to five
by the end of this year the pass rushing
emmanuel agba
uh the the the uh the excellent
play to not let the perimeter players
take over games i think is really shown
in their four-game winning streak
yeah and consider they started oh and
two and they've really turned it around
brian flora is a guy that you have to
consider for coach of the year along
with a kevin stefanski in cleveland
that will be determined over the balance
of the season
uh bengals steelers on sunday crazy
issue with the steelers ben
roethlisberger has injuries to both
knees he's on the covet 19 reserve list
because as you mentioned earlier in the
program he sat next to vance mcdonald on
the flight home from dallas mcdonald
turned out to be positive for
covet 19 on sunday and was shedding
virus they expect ben to play jay glazer
said last night they're going to have a
longer practice on saturday not just a
normal walk through to help ben
make up for lost time but here comes
burrow with two weeks to get ready and
when i spoke to burro
after their upset win of the titans i
i tried to yeah i just threw it out
there because you know they always say
we're taking it one game at a time well
he didn't
he said you know the next four or five
games are very very winnable and then
it's like yeah
steelers coming up but he's not lacking
in confidence
and that's something that the bengals
organization has been lacking for a very
long time
i like the moxie i like the attitude i
like the
hatred the loathing of losing and i
wouldn't be surprised peter
if they go in there and and and steal
one
from pittsburgh because pittsburgh has
been living so dangerously
most of its games the opening is there
if the bengals can
can find a way to cram through it
i thought what was really significant
about the game against tennessee
not that uh
you know didn't throw an interception
was very accurate in the game
played a very confident game i watched a
lot of the game
played a very confident game but the
most significant thing is
first game since he became an nfl
quarterback
that joe burrow was not sacked so i
think what zach taylor is beginning
to understand and to realize is that
there are some things he wants to do
with joe burrow
in getting him to sit back there read
read read
but now he realizes we may not have the
opportunity or the time to do all that
let's get the ball out faster let's have
him be a little bit more mobile in the
pocket
and that's going to become a strength so
to me
especially in a week that you're playing
a great pass rush in the steelers
that could be coming off a zero sack
game huge
for zach taylor the play caller and
obviously for joe burrow
and that is the red flag for all three
of these quarterbacks the potential for
injury we've seen burro and herbert get
hit a lot and we know to his history
they got to stay healthy hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports